so
let me start off uh this is ud singh
application scientist from brama's life
sciences
and my current session
we would be discussing
why ngs
uh what edge does it deliver to the user
uh
that
basically what
benefit it offers
to your research so
those capabilities we are going to
discuss
uh
then we are going to understand how the
workflow goes around your illumina ngs
so from your sample to your final result
what is the intermediate process
that is involved uh in this entire ngs
setup uh we'll discuss that we'll see
we have i have some video also
uh
then i'll be showcasing the entire
illumina sequencing uh range of
sequencers uh so basically it's a
scalable
uh
it is for every user
a novice or a production scale uh
whichever
the user falls in
so apart from that
we'll discuss the library prep options
and that
certain data analysis options that
has
so let's start off
so alumni
with
its uh highly accurate
and deep sequencing and its uh
sequencing by synthesis method is uh
very highly accurate it offers you
most of the data in the q30 range so
with that uh it gives you that ngs
experiment will give you uh the
qualitative information as well as your
quantitative information
so uh
as ashutosh discussed you can check for
in the clinical applications you can
check for your
germline mutation or
somatic mutation
it could be heritable disorders
hereditary hereditary cancers hereditary
disorders are you
an individual can be a carrier also so
prior to marriage
you can check your carrier screening
so you can check the mutations you can
see pairwise differences whether there
is a difference in the genetic makeup of
the two samples
so
um apart from this if you are working on
uh genetic engineering and
let's say you have made some
modifications and you want to check uh
whether it has turned out to be
okay
so uh that
that all can also be checked with this
uh ngs so basically you will run your
samples and you will see whether
the the modifications that you have done
have they occurred successfully
so
these were the qualitative informations
that you can get and
also because the method is highly
sensitive uh you can have your
quantitative informations too so you can
you can check for an employees you can
so basically uh this uh
your
nipt they these are count with account
based methods the nipt and pg is that
that was previously discussed so this
can be also discovered you can check for
uh expression changes um
you can check your gene regulations you
you can basically sequence the the
methyl ohm also so epigenetics this can
be done and also your environmental dna
uh you can go for you can
profile what microbes are
present in your sample or whatever
environmental dna you are targeting
so these are uh
the information that you can get from
ngs and that that is the is that it
offers it it is a very deep sequencing
it gives you a broader discovery power
and also it's highly sensitive so you
you can rely on this
so
now with the onset of covert uh there
was a
requirement of a test
that is highly accurate
uh and also
offers a high throughput capability so
illumina came out with its uh kovic test
and essay
so
basically uh
this this actually
uh covers your entire covert genome uh
it can be
it can be used for as a test as well as
for services so it covers your entire
coverage genome and also the throughput
is pretty high so this is a 307 two
samples in one go
and also it's foolproof because it has
some process controls involved it has
11 human gene targets that are built and
also there is a built pipeline dragon
analysis pipeline that will give you
your uh result
so uh this was the test developed by
illumina uh when this so it it it was
first done in igab uh in daily itself
so
that
it offers you high accuracy and high
throughput
uh
let's move on to
let's understand what is the workflow on
the ngs workflow
so uh it starts off from your sample
so your sample type gave me anything uh
it can be uh from any source
uh so basically uh it should have your
nucleic acids and
the first step would be your sample prep
so from your sample or whichever source
whichever type you will extract your
nucleic acids you will have your dna rna
and then you will go on for your library
preparation
now uh let's understand uh what is
library prep so basically uh
library prep in simple words is
you're
making your nucleic acids compatible to
your sequencing uh the samples the
nucleic acids cannot go cannot go
directly onto the sequencing platform it
needs to be modified so this basically
uh because
the
this is a
short read sequencing
the nucleic acids need to be fragmented
and
they need to come to a certain range
after that certain modification certain
adapters are added to it
and then
that is basically your library and it is
compatible to your sequencing platform
uh
also uh
the uh
any modifications that you do this uh
any nucleic acid it turns out the
library is same for all all the
applications the end library will be
same for all the applications
so also it is called the library because
you basically fragment it and then there
are many short fragments representing
the whole target or the genome that you
are
trying to sequence so that's why it's
also called a library
uh then when you are ready with your
library it goes on to the sequencing and
the sequencer will basically
do your
sbs sequencing by synthesis process and
generate data that will basically lead
each nucleotide individually
in each fragment and then you will have
your uh data that can be
analyzed as per your need
so
this is the common workflow
uh now let's see the library what the
library fragment looks like so basically
this is a library fragment uh
any application or any uh source of
sample anything the end
library fragment will look like this in
every case
so basically this gray region is your
dna insert that is the dna fragment
and then
this
is your basically the modifications that
we have done so it has your three basic
parts p5 then your index and then your
read one sequencing primer so this uh
these three regions are involved in your
sequencing so uh
you will have a
bit more clarity uh in in the next uh
when i play the video so basically you
will understand uh what are the
individual users so p5 basically is
involved in your uh cluster uh
generation process of it will hybridize
to the oligos present on the flow cell
indexes are used for multiplexing so
basically uh
all the samples will be pulled together
and they'll be put into one single run
so basically if you want to segregate uh
you need indexes so these are unique
sequences
uh that are introduced during your
library preparation step for each sample
and at the end when the sequencing is
completed with the use of indexes it is
segregated and read one sequencing
primary uh binding site is basically
where your primer binds and then your
sequencing initiates
so
let me just play this movie
[Music]
sample preparation begins with extracted
and purified dna
the first step in nextera sample
preparation is
tagmentation during tagmentation
transposoms simultaneously fragment and
tag the input dna with adapters
once the adapters have been ligated
reduced cycle amplification adds
additional motifs such as the sequencing
primer binding sites indices and regions
that are complementary to the flow cell
oligos
clustering is a process wherein each
fragment molecule is isothermally
amplified
the flow cell is a glass slide with
lanes
each lane is a channel coated with a
lawn composed of two types of oligos
hybridization is enabled by the first of
the two types of oligos on the surface
this oligo is complementary to the
adapter region on one of the fragment
strands
a polymerase creates a complement of the
hybridized fragment
the double-stranded molecule is
denatured and the original template is
washed away
the strands are clonally amplified
through bridge amplification
in this process the strand folds over
and the adapter region hybridizes to the
second type of oligo on the flow cell
polymerases generate the complementary
strand forming a double-stranded bridge
this bridge is denatured resulting in
two single-stranded copies of the
molecule that are tethered to the flow
cell
the process is then repeated over
and over and occurs simultaneously for
millions of clusters resulting in clonal
amplification of all the fragments
after bridge amplification the reverse
strands are cleaved and washed off
leaving only the forward strands
the three prime ends are blocked to
prevent unwanted priming
[Music]
sequencing begins with the extension of
the first sequencing primer to produce
the first read
with each cycle four fluorescently tag
nucleotides compete for addition to the
growing chain
only one is incorporated based on the
sequence of the template
after the addition of each nucleotide
the clusters are excited by a light
source and a characteristic fluorescent
signal is emitted
this proprietary process is called
sequencing by synthesis
the number of cycles determines the
length of the reed
the emission wavelength along with the
signal intensity determine the base call
for a given cluster all identical
strands are read simultaneously
hundreds of millions of clusters are
sequenced in a massively parallel
process
this image represents a small fraction
of the flow cell
after the completion of the first read
the reed product is washed away
in this step the index 1 read primer is
introduced and hybridized to the
template
the read is generated similar to the
first read
after completion of the index read the
read product is washed off and the three
prime end of the template is d protected
the template now folds over and binds
the second oligo on the flow cell
index 2 is read in the same manner as
index 1.
index 2 read product is washed off at
the completion of this step
polymerases extend the second flow cell
oligo forming a double-stranded bridge
this double-stranded dna is then
linearized and the three prime ends
blocked
the original forward strand is cleaved
off and washed away leaving the reverse
strand
read two begins with the introduction of
the reed2 sequencing primer
as with read 1 the sequencing steps are
repeated until the desired read length
is achieved
the read 2 product is washed away
this entire process generates billions
of reads representing all the fragments
sequences from pooled sample libraries
are separated based on the unique
indices introduced during the sample
preparation
for each sample reads with similar
stretches of base calls are locally
clustered
forward and reverse reads are paired
creating contiguous sequences
these contiguous sequences are aligned
back to the reference genome for variant
identification the paired end
information is used to resolve ambiguous
alignments
[Music]
hi uh so uh the video might have given
you some clarity over the
sequencing by synthesis process
so basically you have your
library fragment
it is then
clonally amplified so how it is done it
is done through a bridge amplification
process and uh it generates clusters it
makes clusters
so uh the on to the flow cell so this is
a flow cell it has your only ghost bound
to it yeah this library fragment is
introduced it goes and hybridizes to
these holy ghosts and then bridge
amplification happens
and so basically it generates the
cluster and cluster generation is
basically done to increase the signal
because the camera just cannot detect a
single nucleotide in corporation in need
something
more so it needs a
high intensity
so that's why clusters are created a
clonal cluster is created so that when
the incorporation happens the signal
from that cluster will be detectable by
the camera
so uh
this is the cluster and then
sequencing happens so your
individual nucleotides go ahead bind the
camera the led excites the camera will
image and then you will have your base
call
so basically it is sequencing by
synthesis that sequences uh one
nucleotide at a time and
so
for like some cases like homopolymer
regions uh it basically has no effect in
your sbs
so apart from other sequencers like iron
torrent which is affected by the
homopolymer range
illumina is not
due to this uh sbs chemistry so uh so it
basically maps one location so this
single point is your cluster and it will
register the signals coming from that
point
uh
at every cycle and it will see
what bases are incorporated and then the
complementary is basically your
original
so this is how it does
and then it will do your so this is how
it registers and you will have your
data
so
how can the samples be mixed so during
the library prep step as i already
discussed we incorporate index
so index are unique sequences and it is
added to the sample during the library
prep step and uh it basically
uh gives it a unique identity for it to
be segregated at the end at the data
analysis step so these uh dual indexes
are placed
on each like on each sample basically
and with this so this is the entire data
sequence with the help of the uh the
indexes the
it will be uh aggregated and
demultiplexed
so
this is how it basically
goes in
and it is then
during your data analysis step and then
you will have your individual data so
from sample one whatever data you have
an individual samples you will get the
data
then
when you have your
individual multiplex
data you can go for your uh further
analysis part
uh using data analysis software you can
utilize your base space uh so this space
is a
analysis uh software or
uh from illumina and then you can have
your uh
uh
variants uh it could be anything for
your vcf file so that can be
done from this
uh now
uh
when you plan an experiment uh basically
there are certain uh
there are certain
questions that you have to ask yourself
uh
how much data do you require
first thing then uh what would be the
read length and according to that read
length whether uh do you want it to be a
single end or a paradigm
so
data is basically uh whichever genome
you are targeting or uh whatever region
you are targeting and how much coverage
do you need how many times do you want
to sequence so then you will have uh
your
the total data that you want
also whichever genome the size of it uh
according to that you will see how what
would be the read length
and similarly with the along with this
you will decide your single or paid and
read so whether if it is a very small so
let's just start off with your uh let's
see this
single and paid ends why why single or
parent so basically if you have if you
your data requirement is very less and
your target is also small uh in case of
let's say small rna so basically it's
just 20 to 22.
so
you you can basically cover it in a
single
read itself it
if you are just doing a basic counting
experiment
and when you are doing something like a
dino or something which has in which you
need more data and
you want to align it
so basically then you go for your paid
and sequencing so paired and sequencing
basically offers you two benefits uh at
the end of sequencing there is a loss in
data quality so if you if you are
overlapping it then you might cover it
in your second read second is the
alignment part so basically two two
sequences needs to be aligned to the
reference genome so basically you have
two points to align so it
it goes for uh it
gives you a better alignment
in that part so this is the benefit of
period and sequencing and alumni has
that
offers your parent sequencing and also
um
in you can if you have dino
see if you want to do dino sequencing
you can you can go for larger
leads than 2 cos 300 that is offered on
aluminum ic instrument
so uh
we we have i have
given you how uh the uh what edge does
ngs uh ngs offers and also
what is the workflow now let's
understand what are the sequencing
systems that illumina has to offer
so basically we have this range it
starts off from your ic to the smallest
machine i see 100 to our biggest machine
novaseq
so this one generates around 1gb of data
and this one generates around 6000 gbs
of data
and intermediate we have certain
machines the bench top ones this is also
been stopped uh
these uh
mini seek my seek neck seek and then you
have certain
so this one will overlap in your this
next 550 has flexible power so that's
why it comes in low throughput as well
as your high throughput and then we have
uh
nexi 2000 it does the recent machine
it's
it's id advanced with no fluid x inside
also this one has no fluid x inside
so this is our entire range let's move
on to individual sequencers and let's
see what it has to offer
so uh our smallest machine i seek
hundred um it's on a
a
single channel chemistry it basically
has only one channel and uh
it's basically on and off so zero one
zero one that that's how it base calls
and with this it offers you 1.2 gb of
data and 4 million leads and so this
machine
is pretty simple
uh it has no fluid x built in so
so low maintenance no washing steps
so
and also uh this is also user
installable
so uh what you can do so basically the
data is
is less so you can go for small gene
panels uh small targets amplicons so
this is what you can do in this uh
sequencing system
uh
so the main benefits main highlights are
this is
a very low cost machine
highly reliable
because
it has
because it has no fluid x inside it is
it
basically requires low maintenance
and all the fluid x and all the liquid
part is basically built into the
cartridge all the fluid export is built
into the cartridge so that's why this
machine has basically less moving parts
and so that
this is more reliable simplified
workflow because
after the library prep there are certain
steps that needs to be done prior to
adding it to the sequencer there are
just simple pipetting steps but
here that part is also much more
simplified so no denaturation of the
library is required onboard denaturation
happens in this machine itself
uh setup is pretty simple
this is a touch screen led screen and
with our user friendly interface you can
just set up the run within a few minutes
and this machine is also because very
simple it is customer installable so
basically you just receive the box you
uh
place it onto your desktop and plug and
play
so that's how it goes
uh
coming on to uh
this miniseq so it's basically offered
it offers you a higher data than your ic
machine
this offers you 7.5 gigabases of data
so
uh 25 million reads
so this miniseq machine uh offers you
two options of sequencing with output
and high output so two simple options
and basically uh it has less uh data
so
the applications here are also your
small genomes and basically this
miniseq machine is mostly used for
in india is mostly used for your hla
typing applications
so the highlights major highlights are
low capital so this is uh again
from uh start start starting range so
this is a low capital uh machine
uh simple onboard data analysis so lrm
built in we'll discuss a lot and further
slides
and also uh you can go for your small
genomes
so
small rna sequencing can be done
resequencing can be done sorry
sequencing is uh an application where
when you want to
do some
if you want to refer so you have the
reference already there and you want to
do it
so this can be done uh also uh these
machines are also utilized for
your
well let's say you want to set up a run
in our biggest sequences then overseek
or the next 2000 let's say so the there
the run cost is pretty high and want to
validate those libraries whether the
performance of the those libraries are
good uh to be sequenced on the bigger
machine so that that is also done the
validation parts are done in our
lower range of sequencers
and also uh you can go for your amp if
you have certain amplifiers you want to
sequence and small panel small different
panels can also be done in this machine
now coming on to our myc so here are
certain this machine will uh has certain
highlights so basic uh in
certain highlights so this uh actually
offers you paid and 300 so this is the
highest read length that the uh
that is offered
by my seek in the entire illumina range
so paired in 300
is offered by my seeks and the data is
15 gbs and 25 other specs are mostly
similar to your mini c this is the major
highlight that is offered by my c
beard in 300
and uh so and also the another big
highlight of this machine is that it has
a very uh high scalable sequencing
option so basically you have four
types of kits available uh the nano
micro a standard version two and a
standard version three so my seek is the
um only machine that offers your parent
300
the longest street length as well as uh
very high scalable
options of sequencing so if you have
less data you can go for nano if you
want more data you can go for v3 or also
if you want to go for the 600 cycles 600
cycles are basically the paired and 300
is offered in the version 3 only
so these are
the applications again
mostly the specs are similar to many
seeks so small uh genomes can be done
and apart from this one major
highlighting over sequencing wherein you
will require a larger read length so
that can be done also library qc so
library qc is that part which i
discussed so if you want to
qc check the libraries check the
performance of the live user so this can
be done on the smaller machines prior to
going to the bigger machines
so the basic uh so you you have your
long read
and you have your scalable options and
again the the workflow is pretty simple
and it's simple for all the alumni
sequencers
so now let's move on to nexiq 550 so now
this is
basically
a big upgrade here so from 15 gbs you
move on to 120 gb
and the reads here are 400 million reads
now so this is
where you will unlock certain
applications that could not be done on
the
sequence sequencers that we have
discussed previously
so 120 gb is unlock some applications
like your
transcript like your
exome sequencing
and also um if you want to go for a
human whole genome that can also be done
but only one sample can be done but yes
it offers you the capability of doing
that so two options high output and mid
output
two simple options you have
uh
so the higher one the high output one
offers you the the highest range so this
is 120 gb and 400 million reads
and
apart from this uh you have your holder
so this
gives you a high throughput applications
and you can basically go for your
transcriptome wherein you will if you
want to do a human transcriptome you'll
be targeting 50 million reads so for 50
million reads uh basically was um in its
in the next 550 from where you can start
your transcriptomics experiment
and the previous sequencers the highest
read
reads were 50 million leads paired and
so basically uh transcriptome is not
possible there
so next week 550 is the machine from
wherein if you want to do transmit term
this is the lewis mission that you need
to have
um also you can go for exam panels and
if you want to do a image you know that
can also be done
so also uh this machine has a major
highlight that
it can also go for your array
application so
and so basically the infinium arrays
they they can this machine can scan
those arrays so you can also do that
part
uh
coming on to our next upgrade that is
your nexi 2000 so now here uh with the
next week 2000 alumni has made major
advancement in this machine
and uh so basically this machine is
fluid x friendly
fluid is free sorry it's fluid x-free
and so basically
less maintenance it does not have you
need not perform any wash
uh you so all the fluid eggs are
basically uh built onto the cartridge
itself
and it has also modified upgraded its uh
imaging modules on the camera so it's
higher resolution and basically this led
to uh your
smaller
flow cell so this is a very highly high
density flow cell
and basically it's much more smaller
than the nexsig 550 flow cell
and
apparently this offers you much so three
times more data 360 gbs of data in your
in this the biggest blue cell that this
offers and 1.2 billion reads
uh
with this with the next e2000 p3 flow
cell so this machine is the recent one
from illumina
it is fluid x-free it has a higher
resolution and also
it goes for your
miniaturized sequencing reaction so
basically
the cartridges
they are built so so that technology is
such that they require less reagent
so less reagent means the cartridge will
be also small and
the small volumes means your storage
footprint will be less so basically you
will be saving on your uh storage cost
also so good
so that that is the is that this machine
offers also uh
next c2000 has your dragon bite bioid
platform built in
and also uh
this machine
uh
unlike other alumni platforms uh it's
based on linux so there's
also the user interface is pretty simple
the the gui is very simple so this
when it boots up this is the screen that
you have
uh it's pretty simple the the workflow
steps are very easy and
so basically on board denaturation
happens inside this machine itself
and the run setup options are also uh
diver so basically you can you you have
many you have your local you have your
cloud as well as your hybrid options to
set up a run
so uh let's move on to our novaseq
6000 system so this is the biggest uh
sequencer that alumni offers and it is
not a benchtop system it's a standalone
so uh there's any any sequencing any
project you name it and it can be done
on overseas so basically it offers you
6000 gb of data
in
its full capacity
and also uh let's discuss in the next
slide so basically these are the uh
options that it offers so uh from sp to
s4 uh so this is the flexibility and the
scalability that this offers and the
flow cells are basically patterned
highly high very high density pattern
flow cells
so a s4 flow cell offers you three db
and two of these flow cells can go in a
single
when you run so basically nova c has two
uh it can hold two sequence uh two flow
cells and they can be run uh
independently
so when you
go for two of these s4 runs it offers
you 6 tb of data
let's move on to understand what can be
done what are so
this will give you a glimpse of
how many samples
you can basically do so basically this
is a high throughput sequencer a human
genome on a single s4 flow cell you can
do 24 samples
uh if you are going for
and also
if you are targeting 30x genome coverage
uh
when you are doing exome uh let's say
exome and if you are targeting 100x
genome coverage 250 of these
libraries can be sequenced on a single
s4 flow cell and transcriptome when you
are targeting uh somewhat or more than
50 million reads so basically then you
can go for your
200 sample so this is a high throughput
sequencer and also individual lanes can
be utilized for uh
individuals uh library type also
different library types uh basically you
have to follow a different workflow for
that but yes
it offers you that capability also that
the individual lanes can run different
libraries
so uh this was all for the entire range
so basically you have your uh
from i seek
to your nova c that basically enables
each user so a user can be new to
sequencing and they can basically go for
your uh smaller sequencers the smaller
ic miniseq mysq
and
there is a sequencer nexique 550 which
has flexible power it can go for you and
a new user can also use it and also an
experienced one or the one which has a
higher data requirements and also uh
then we have your uh the production
scale
your next week 2000 and your nova 6 so
all this
has an entire range it enables each of
uh all the
users um whatever their
data requirement is they can have
they can go for whatever sequencer and
the same thing
now let's uh move on to the library prep
options that illumina offers so
uh
we here are certain uh applications that
the major application so you have your
dna
uh you you dna libraries can be made and
the rna
to check your
gene expressions then also you have your
methyl ohm study where you can uh you
can check for your gene regulations
so uh these are different library prep
method methods and uh
alumni offers different library prep
solutions for
each catering to each uh
application
so these are certain uh kits are listed
here so uh some of them are can be
clinical also some can be a normal like
a whole genome library
will be just
for sequencing your dna so basically you
can
have dna from any source any uh
any uh
sample so
that can be prepared from that library
uh prep kit and then you can go ahead
and sequence as per on the sequencer of
your choice whatever whatever data you
want
so there are certain uh kits that are
very broad range and there are certain
kits that are very specific like your uh
your clinical um
library kits that
let's say your very cpgs so they
are very specific for certain
applications
so
and also these library prep
are
automated on your uh the major players
of automations out there so agilent your
hamilton beckman birkin albert can so
there so basically these protocols
can be automated or are automated on
these uh
automated automation platforms so if if
you want to go for high throughput uh
library preparation that can be also
done
so there are third-party
automation
proto this
machines available
so uh
we have understood uh the library prep
kit part we have understood the
sequencing and we haven't seen the
workflow let's understand at the end
when you have the data
what what solution does it
actually offer so
we are not covering informatics here
that's it's been told very clearly
[Music]
okay okay so let's let's
keep this part
okay
yeah so let's take the q a you have
anything else apart from informatics
then you can go ahead no no no so
basically that was just lrm nothing more
yeah yeah then then let's let's hold
this uh we can take okay
yeah sure sure so so that that was all
for the session so let me just summarize
uh in this session i have covered your
basic
uh
ngs
edge that it delivers and also the
workflow so from the sample how it's the
library is made and then
how it goes on to the sequencer and how
it is sequenced
i have showcased in the entire alumni
range so from your smallest sequencer to
the biggest sequencer and also uh the
library prep solutions that are good
offers
so that was all for the session um
if you have any questions you you can uh
ask them
yes there is a question at chat uh it's
from saga uh he's asking what strategy
should we go for
m a rna-seq
okay okay okay so it's um
basically mi rna uh very small
very small
uh
so it's a very small rna and
uh you can basically go for your small
rna kit and
that can be done on your uh
these normal small sequencers that can
be done so uh
there's a kit to seek small rna kit that
can be
that can be utilized for your live
library preparation and whatever data
you require according to that and then a
number of samples also the number of
samples and the amount of data you want
accordingly your run can be set up and
basically here you target for a very
small read length
it is single end so for your mi rna you
will go for single end because it's a
very small size
yes the next question is which one we
can use for chipseek
i think they are asking the kick name i
guess
am i right
hello
kit name and instrument okay okay yes
okay so uh
this i think i will have to get back uh
i will just get back over the email
which uh kit for chip c can be utilized
and instrument is basically um
so it depends on how many samples you uh
have and the data you require so that in
that way you decide which sequencer to
go for
so this this has to be decided by the
user according to that we can suggest
you which uh
sequencer you can go ahead and sequences
so regarding the library prep kit i will
get back to you i will uh write it over
so i will share it with you
yes i think the next question is on me
what are all the information we can
extract out of rna-seq so we can get a
splice site variance we can get an
expression profile and we can get a
differential expression profile and
downstream of course pathways can be
analyzed
um
gene ontology studies
so basically what question we are asking
that it depends upon that we'll be doing
the downstream analysis so pathway is
one of it there are multiple ways it can
be analyzed i think uh pine better have
a plan for you publix i think they will
be uh
uh using some tools specifically on this
i believe
so are you
yes i actually just wanted to interrupt
here for a second only so we at the
informatics part we have two day
sessions like over 10 years of training
which is planned for tomorrow and day
after tomorrow so anyone who is like
inquisitive about the informatics part
uh we would like to invite them for
tomorrow tomorrow thank you
you can go ahead uh i was just telling
about the informatics session that you
were explaining that tomorrow we have uh
with pine biotech so tomorrow and day
after tomorrow we have two days of
genomics metagenomics and
transcriptomics data analysis and then
that will be followed by
some of the chemi informatics strategies
that can be utilized for drug discovery
thank you
thank you
there's no more question uh thank you so
much for the talk with it and thank you
for all the responses like say for all
the replies
for the questions i think one more is
coming can basically be useful
uh so saga i think i can take this
offline because we are not discussing
any illumina related solutions here
right so anything on the instrument
sequencing related we can answer
analysis since it's been covered next
two days we are not taking any questions
on that but offline if you want we can
you can reach premise at any time right
yeah thank you so much
uh so thank you so much again with it
for the talk as well as for all the
responses
let's bring nithya in picture now
yeah thanks thanks raja let me just stop
sharing my screen
hello
yes so nithya is our product manager for
10x uh he'll be discussing about all the
10x related solutions now
[Music]
can you share your screen nithya
is there any break or we can go ahead
i was thinking that there is a break
the timing is one pm to
2 pm
yeah we can continue so this is the last
session i think right
yes yeah this is the last question yes
yeah so let's conclude and i would want
everyone to be free is it like holidays
right
so we don't want to break the curiosity
yes
yes it is going really well it's
wonderful sessions and i think it's all
connected so we are all in twitter to
learn more thank you so much